these titles this coming week wherever
books are sold and watch for many of
these authors to appear in the near
future on book tv
[Music]
for the people to say that we don't want
to fight no more
[Music]
one
day good evening everybody i'm gaddy
levy i'm the executive director of the
temple emmanuel striker center and i'm
honored to welcome you to our final
virtual event of the summer
before we begin i want to thank the
hundreds of thousands of you from across
the country and the world who have
joined our virtual community
proving that learning and engaging even
at a distance makes us stronger
i invite you to check out our full
catalogue on our website we will be back
in october to begin a semester that we
are very proud of please join us again
soon
when we plan tonight's program the
afghan war felt far away
a conflict that has gone on so long that
it almost disappeared from the evening
news
then president biden pulled out all
americans troops leading to a messy
withdrawal and letting tonight's event a
new sense of importance and a new set of
questions
we are honored that craig whitlock joins
us tonight to discuss a nation-building
project doomed to failure as laid out in
his newest book the afghanistan papers
which you can purchase right now using
the link in the chat window
an investigative reporter for the
washington post craig has covered the
global war on terrorism since 2001 and
has won some of journalism highest
annuals
tonight he will be in conversation with
his colleague
carlos lazada the post pulitzer
prize-winning nonfiction book critic
if you have a question please feel free
to post it in the chat window at any
time we will get to as many as possible
and now please join me in welcoming
craig whitlock and carlos lasada
thanks
thank you very much um it is such an
honor to be here and i could not be more
excited to be in conversation with my
colleague craig whitlock who i've
admired uh from afar at the washington
post for many years
um
and to discuss a a book in a subject
that could not be more
more timely um
and and uh crucial in this in this
moment um so you know just to start off
there's a bunch of questions i want to
ask you craig about about the book but
first off
you know in in the debates over this war
now is it looks like we're looking back
on it
it's hard to shake the notion that
america
lost this war the taliban is is back in
power yet you hear president biden
saying look we we accomplished what we
wanted to accomplish there you know we
defeated al qaeda in afghanistan so how
do you how do you square that that
difference was it ever possible
to truly
win this war and what would have winning
it actually have have looked like
well those are questions carlos we
should have asked a long time ago or
certainly our leaders should have asked
what were they trying to accomplish
uh and it is hard i think for biden to
square
the result uh with what what he's saying
we accomplished what we set out to when
you see images of the taliban taking
over the whole country uh swooping into
the airport in kabul after u.s troops
leave i mean there's no question that
the united states and and the afghan
government
uh have have lost this conflict that you
know from the taliban's perspective
they're as victorious as they could hope
for
uh but the question is what did we hope
to accomplish i think people remember
back in 2001 after the september 11th
attacks the whole purpose of
uh going to war in afghanistan was to
attack al-qaeda was to
eliminate the threat from al-qaeda this
global terrorist group so that they
couldn't carry out any
more terrorist attacks
against united states targets or against
allies around the world and uh in
afghanistan we were pretty successful
with that within the first six months uh
by
april of 2002 just about all of al
qaeda's leaders had been
captured killed or had fled afghanistan
they really didn't have a presence left
after the spring of 2002
but from that point forward that's when
mission creeps started to set in pretty
quickly
and
as a lot of the documents show for this
book uh very bluntly people said we lost
focus uh became unclear what our goals
and objectives were both militarily and
politically and strategically and uh for
the last 19 years we've never really
been able to set out uh explicitly what
we're hoping to accomplish in
afghanistan i think one thing president
biden points to a lot uh is the the
death of osama bin laden in 2001 when he
was killed in pakistan and biden says
you know that was that was the last
thing we wanted to accomplish but uh you
know and that's certainly true in terms
of the original goal of dismantling al
qaeda but you know then that raises a
question of what were we really trying
to accomplish for the 10 years since
then
why do you think american leaders
believe they can
remake other countries other societies
transform their politics whether it's
it's vietnam or iraq or or afghanistan
you've had president bush
president obama um president trump you
know all
um saying they would not engage in
nation building um and yet and yet they
they did over over 20 years why
uh that's a really good question and i
think one that our leaders haven't
answered there is one interview in the
afghanistan papers with
a a former navy seal named jeffrey
eggers who worked at the white house on
the national security staff under bush
and obama and he served in afghanistan
too
and he he raised that same question said
you know why do we think we can
transform societies like this why do we
uh take on these enormous tasks uh as a
country uh and he said it really gets
it's a question of human psychology you
know why do we think we can do this
accomplish these things you know why
don't we take a step back and and
question some of these basic assumptions
what were we thinking trying to
really transform uh not just create a
new afghan government new afghan
institutions but really in some ways
transform afghan society
uh you know yet this was a country that
americans knew very little about uh
going in and we never really got a
better uh grasp of of what afghan
culture and society was like there are
very few us officials who speak the
language even you speak any of the
afghan languages even today 20 years
later so you know it's i think the
answer is hubris uh we tend to think
that because we're the most powerful
nation in the world in many ways that we
can do anything and some of this is the
military mindset in america that uh in
the u.s military culture is sort of a
can-do
culture and spirit they they say we can
do anything right and many times that's
admirable
uh but sometimes people need to take a
step back and say what's realistic here
can you tell us a little about the the
genesis of this book
um
because in some ways i think the the
origin story itself is is revelatory
about the way that that the war was
prosecuted and that officials um spoke
or or did not publicly speak about it
yeah sure so you know like all good
stories it started out with a tip
uh five years ago i got a
contact of mine said you know i heard
that there this
uh kind of obscure federal agency called
the special inspector general for
afghanistan
had conducted an interview with uh
recently retired general michael flynn
and today flynn's kind of notorious for
being a political extremist
but back in 2016 he had just retired
from the military during his army career
he was well known uh he had a pretty
good reputation in military intelligence
and he had overseen nato and us
intelligence in afghanistan uh for a
number of years so i heard that this
agency conducted this interview with
flynn at that time flynn was in the
headlines for his support of trump and
he had gone to the republican convention
saying uh lock her up lock her up about
hillary clinton uh so just we were
interested in what he said from a news
perspective about the war in afghanistan
because flynn was known to be very
outspoken so i was just curious
um
i found out that the inspector general
had in fact conducted this interview
when i asked for a transcript of it
because this hadn't been made public at
first the inspector general's office
said sure shouldn't be a problem just
send it your request in writing
long story short as trump started to do
well in the polls and was eventually
elected and flynn became his national
security adviser
uh the inspector general denied my
request and we ended up having to go to
court the washington post filed a
freedom of information lawsuit because
our contention was this was public
information
along the way besides the flynn
interview i heard that the inspector
general had actually done this as part
of a bigger project called lessons
learned where they had interviewed over
400 people who were involved in the war
in some capacity from
generals and diplomats to white house
officials and aid workers in for a
program like called lessons learned
where they were trying to sort of assess
what people thought were mistakes have
been made in afghanistan
uh so naturally that caught my attention
too because
uh this was 2016 2017 and
people thought the war was winding down
but we thought maybe this would be a
good way to get our arms around
journalistically this assessment of what
did go wrong in afghanistan
long story short again we had to go to
court again a second time
the inspector general really did not
want to release any of these documents
but we ultimately prevailed it took
three years but we're able to get
about 2000 pages of these notes and
transcripts of these interviews and
they were really blunt you know a lot of
these people again ambassadors generals
were saying we didn't know what we were
doing in
afghanistan uh we we didn't have a
strategy we didn't have a campaign plan
we didn't know what we were doing we
didn't understand the society and so
that the criticism was really blistering
and a complete contrast from what had
been said in public over the preceding
decades so at that point we knew we had
a a good news story and we decided to
make it into a pretty big project
and in december 2019 we we published a
series and we also posted all the notes
and interviews we obtained in court so
people could see for themselves
what's uh what's great about the the
book i think is that it not only
captures you know what what you
learned through the lessons learned
project and and what you what you
reported in the washington post but you
know there's a series of of documents
and cables and oral histories and and
new material that really
you know creates creates even even a
fuller picture in in one of those um
that really struck me uh in in reading
the book
um you have um
uh many of these kind of memos from
donald rumsfeld you know the late don
rumsfeld who was the defense secretary
at the time of 911 and two years into
the war like a two full years into the
war he's complaining in these memos you
know internal i have no visibility into
who the bad guys are um which is
remarkable to to think about that you
don't really know
you know who the enemy is um so let me
put that to you who was the enemy in in
the war in afghanistan you know al qaeda
the taliban now isis k like what you
know who who you know who were to quote
runsville the bad guys that america was
fighting
well right so
it sounds like a simple question but
uh we don't know who the bad guys were
we couldn't distinguish them you know as
as i said before at first it was clear
al qaeda
was the enemy those were the bad guys
but
by the time rumsfeld wrote that memo al
qaeda was gone in afghanistan but we
were still fighting people right so we
were fighting people that
we couldn't always understand what their
motivations were what group or network
they were part of you know we we had
this
term the taliban
but you know the taliban covered any
number of insurgent groups sometimes
they were you know criminal networks or
smugglers or people who are just opposed
to the people in charge in afghanistan
and you know as ramsar said you know who
are the bad guys and this is kind of the
simplistic view
the americans had in afghanistan they
they were good guys and bad guys right
that's how we looked at it but the
problem was
a lot of the good guys i mean americans
like to think of ourselves as good guys
but our allies in the afghan government
these warlords uh corrupt government
officials they weren't always so good
and the population didn't like them very
much and
the bad guys was just shorthand for
anyone who was shooting at us and yet we
couldn't always define their motivations
and this this was a problem that the
united states never figured out i mean
if you fast forward
uh about 15 years when rumsfeld wrote
that memo
uh
the war commander in i think it was
2017 general john campbell was
testifying before congress
and he was asked by senators is the
taliban the enemy you know are we
fighting the taliban and general
campbell kind of you know
stammered and paused and didn't want to
answer the question and finally he said
no our country's just like you know the
taliban's not the enemy you know we're
trying to reconcile with them
politically so
you know and even in recent days it's
been very confusing the images coming
from afghanistan that you know the
taliban took over but there's been
cooperation at a military level between
uh us generals and the taliban we sent
the cia director to talk to the taliban
leadership recently uh you know there's
a question are we going to recognize
them diplomatically and this all begs
the question of why were we fighting the
taliban for the last 20 years
now early on you know you it makes sense
in that the taliban government
had hosted al qaeda prior to 2001 and
they refused to give up bin laden so
there's no question the taliban was
allied with with al-qaeda but
we started out with this war with the
fight against al qaeda and we ended up
getting dragged into or inserting
ourselves in a long-running civil war in
afghanistan uh where we really didn't
understand the different factions very
well
one of the um i mean the the kind of
overriding
um you know thrust of the book that
makes it so powerful is that you
contrast
the
uh you know private impressions of you
know a series of diplomatic and military
and non-governmental leaders involved in
afghanistan with the
public declarations um and the the sort
of enormous contrast
between them
but you know as as you mentioned early
on you know compared to iraq you know
afghanistan was the so-called good war
right the one that made sense you know
that's where al qaeda was
um
you know when they perpetrated the 9 11
attacks so why did officials feel the
need to
lie or spin to maintain support for
the war that at least initially you know
had had some support
both nationally and internationally yeah
a really good question why would they
feel the need because initially people
were behind it back in 2001 you know
polls showed that you know more than 80
percent of americans supported the
military
operations in war in afghanistan again
it was seen as a war of self-defense a
just cause but i think that's precisely
the reason
why our leaders couldn't really bring
themselves to be uh blunt and honest
when things weren't going well because
you know the united states thought we
had won this war back in 2002 the
taliban had been removed from power uh
you know al qaeda was gone uh you know
the bush administration had essentially
declared victory so
afterward what american president
uh you know what general what secretary
of state wants to say admit that they're
slowly losing a war
uh that americans thought we had won
and that was seen as a just cause nobody
wants to admit failure particularly in a
situation like that so i think there was
it started out as a reluctance to uh
admit that things weren't going well but
the longer we were there and the deeper
the dishonesty got where our leaders
were saying we were making progress that
the strategy was working that we were
winning you know the the whole gets dug
deeper and deeper and then it becomes
much harder
uh to admit the truth
there are some other reasons too i think
in military culture again it's it's very
hard to contradict the boss right you
never want to show up your commander
and you never want to undercut or
contradict the commander-in-chief so if
you're a general or a war commander and
you start
saying that things aren't going well
that's not what the president or the
white house wants to hear
and one episode in the book
you know i go to in some detail is that
there there was one general who was
admitting that things weren't going well
this his name was general david
mckiernan he was the war commander under
uh bush at the end of his second term
and the start of obama's first term and
he was really the first general to say
yeah things aren't going well the
taliban's getting stronger and you know
this isn't going in the right direction
we need more troops and more resources
so he was he was fairly honest about
that well he gets relieved of command he
gets fired in the spring of 2009 he
becomes the first american war commander
since general douglas macarthur in korea
to get fired in the middle of a war
and there was no good explanation given
for this the defense secretary at the
time bob gates uh held a press
conference said he was relieving
mckiernan but when asked why he was
doing it he just said i just thought we
needed to change we needed new thinking
but he was pressed again and again why
was why are you firing him and he really
wouldn't give a concrete reason
but in documents we obtained for the
book uh there were some army officers in
afghanistan who worked with mckiernan
who said that
shortly before he was fired he confessed
to them he said you know i did too good
of a job telling the truth of how bad
things are over here and he was paying
the price
and of course you better believe after
that every officer in the defense
department takes note of that right
they're not you know
they know that if they speak the truth
or they contradict their boss they could
lose their job so you know there was
there was no real incentive to be honest
with the american people when things
were not going well
there's so many things you've said in
that in that response that just prompt
other other questions one one word that
i will never think of in the same way
after reading your book is progress
right um you know always throughout the
war you know the line is we're making
progress we're not saying we're winning
we're making progress right and you know
that felt like this kind of meaningless
filler term to kind of avoid ugly truths
but were there moments that you feel
looking back on it there there was
some sense of tangible sustainable
progress
um where things you know could have been
headed in a in a better direction
yeah so progress was clear it was a
talking point right and all the generals
mimicked each other that way because
uh you know they heard the other guys
say it and they knew it was an
acceptable way to describe what was
going on and made people feel like
things were going in the right direction
so
they did say winning every once in a
while but progress was definitely the
word they loved the most and they they
also liked the phrase turning the corner
when things weren't going so well but
they said yeah but
we're turning the corner now right and
uh so those were two of the common
phrases um you know there were times it
felt like there was progress i think
superficially but it was almost an
illusion
uh during obama's first term when he
sent the surge of a hundred thousand
troops to afghanistan uh it looked like
they were maybe making some progress in
terms of uh
you know taking a real
weakening the taliban
uh building up the afghan government you
know we bought we built tons of schools
and clinics and hospitals and roads in
afghanistan we spent a ton of money
over there and that looked on the
surface like progress
but underneath what became clear in in
the documents i obtained for the book
was
people didn't have any faith that this
was going to last that they knew there
were some fundamental flaws in the whole
strategy number one was that
the whole purpose of obama's surge
strategy was to build up the afghan
government
so that the afghan people particularly
in rural areas would side with the
government over the taliban that they
would fight against the taliban
to protect their own government but in
the field people said that the afghan
government was clearly corrupt that
afghans had no faith in their lone
leaders they didn't have much faith in
their own army and they particularly
hated the afghan police because they saw
them as as thieves and and shakedown
artists so uh you you'd see this in
different interviews where with afghans
where they were asking
why are you siding with the taliban or
why aren't you supporting the government
uh with all this work the americans are
doing and the tribal elders would say
well we don't like the taliban but we
really don't like the government
and we're waiting to see who wins or we
think the taliban is actually as bad as
they are they're more responsive to our
needs than the government is so if you
if you scratch the surface it became
clear that these
illusions of progress were going to
vanish
one thing i'd love to hear your thoughts
on um is perceptions of the afghan
security forces uh throughout the book
you know you show officials making
positive statements about the the
numbers and the skills and the and the
training
of the afghan security phases statements
which are you know at odds with those
that you also show uh you know when when
you show what they were really thinking
about it now you know in the course of
this withdrawal
you've had the bible administration you
know often expressing
uh sort of
between you know surprise and disdain
uh for the afghan security forces that
you know they should have fought more
effectively against the the taliban um
you know
was that ever really possible um you
know given what you saw about about
their
officials true impressions of how the
security forces were developing
yeah not the way we went about building
an afghan army i don't think it was
possible there were just so many
structural problems and flaws that kind
of guaranteed that this this whole
project wasn't gonna work
um again getting back to that question
about hubris you know why did we think
we could
create this pretty enormous afghan army
and paramilitary police force of as many
as 350 000
uh uniform personnel i mean that's a
pretty big
army uh from scratch
that and we designed it to look like the
us army where they had this very
centralized chain of command and they're
expected to use advanced weapon systems
and uh
this bureaucratic logistical resupply
system and you know we made we built
them an army that looked like ours
because that's what we knew how to do
but
in interviews we obtained oral history
interviews with army us army officers
trainers uh going back to 2005 2006 2007
they were just
withering in their assessments of this
they said you know we were we were
training these afghan recruits and it
was just beyond our abilities to make
this work they they noted that
illiteracy was an enormous problem that
more than 90 of the afghan recruits
couldn't read or write
many of them couldn't count there was
one u.s official said you know and you
know you go to an afghan recruit and he
can tell you the names of his brothers
and sisters but he can't tell you how
many he has
or other afghan recruits they they
couldn't count they couldn't go one two
three or couldn't tell their colors
so he said how are we supposed to in the
matter of a few weeks of basic training
uh
mold these people into an army in our
own image it was just a fool's errand
but as you point out in public
u.s military officials kept saying we're
making progress the afghans are doing
great you know they're more and more
capable all the time they're going to
defeat the taliban
even though
they knew because their own trainers
were telling them this that you know the
afghans they couldn't shoot straight
they they
weren't uh very inspired to defend their
own government you could see this coming
for a long time
um you
you offer examples of these kinds of
misleading statements coming from from
all administrations that have been
engaged in this war
um
but you also write that when it came to
distorting statistics uh you know
indicators of progress right um that the
obama administration sort of took it to
a new level
um what did you mean by that should we
conclude that essentially the the obama
team were were the worst offenders in
terms of
of deceiving the public this gets to a
question that one of one of um
uh one of the audience members daniel
writes you know how do you think of
president obama's role in this war
yeah well the deceptions were bad across
the board but in reading these documents
and interviews we obtained
i mean it was worse than i thought i had
covered the pentagon for several years
from 2010 to 2016. so i was used to the
the spin and the happy talk about uh how
things were going and i mean you take
that with a grain of salt but it's you
know it's a part of
unfortunately covering the government a
lot of times but when you read these
documents you realize it was
you know that they had taken it to a
much more cynical level there was one
interview
uh
lessons learned interview with a member
of obama's national security team at the
white house uh this person's name was
redacted from the document but we know
somebody worked at the white house at a
pretty high level on the national
security council and he said you know we
manipulated all the metrics for the
duration of the war and what he was
talking about metrics he was saying all
the stats to show progress like number
of schools built
uh roads paved or violence levels going
up or down he said you know we had tons
of statistics but we intentionally
manipulated them to make it look like we
were making progress and he said we did
this for two reasons he said very
bluntly one was to make the people in
charge look good and second to you know
maintain public support for the war so
we could keep troops over there so that
there wouldn't be this clamor for the
troops to return
so you know it that's pretty bad right i
mean that's what happened in vietnam and
this person's admitting that this
happened not just in the field but at
the white house at the national security
level all the way up to the president so
when they would give material to the
president for a speech
obama would
rattle off statistics that they knew uh
were intentionally deceptive
that's pretty damning statement to come
from somebody worked directly for the
president but
you'd see this in other documents too
they just would say we collect all sorts
of statistics but we knew we couldn't
you know we had to spin them in a way to
always make it look like we were making
progress
um
sometimes i think obama and sometimes he
told some of the biggest fibs about the
war in
december of 2014
there was a ceremony at u.s military
headquarters in kabul and obama put out
a statement saying this was the war in
afghanistan is coming to a responsible
conclusion and he announced the end of
the combat mission for u.s troops
and obama and his uh war commander at
the time general john campbell said uh
the us troops there's gonna be a few
thousand of them staying in the country
but they're only there as advisors the
afghans are ready to take charge of
their own security and they're going to
be the ones fighting against the taliban
well obama and his generals knew that
wasn't true that u.s troops were still
going to be involved in combat
in fact more than 100 u.s troops died in
combat after obama made that that
announcement
all u.s soldiers in the war zone
received combat pay
when they died they received combat
decorations and the most vivid example
of how combat was going on was was from
the air we continued to fly
more than a thousand air strikes and
bombings a year
in which we were killing lots of people
both taliban and civilians so this idea
that the combat mission was over was was
just a complete fabrication and yet
obama knew this and the reason
he clung to this description was because
he knew that popular support for the war
was waning
and he wanted americans to think that
u.s troops were no longer in harm's way
and that you know they shouldn't push
for an end to the war he was trying to
buy time but again the deception really
just
it went deeper and deeper as time went
on
when you raised obama's um speech in
2014 it reminded me of one of the
one of the moments that i've completely
missed or forgotten that that i
i um i saw in your book um
and that is that that wasn't the first
time that we've declared you know the
the end of combat operations that that
the same at the same time that president
bush
was
um you know having his mission
accomplished moment about iraq that don
rumsfeld was in
in kabul declaring the end of combat
operations in 2003 i mean it was you
know it it's just you know thinking
about reading that's part of why by sort
of reading this book right now um is
is just so crazy um to see you know
these other moments when we've kind of
declared that this thing is
is over but you you mentioned um you
mentioned vietnam briefly and we have a
question from um
a member of the audience
um
michael who asks you know do you view
the debacle in kabul as similar to
saigon in
1975 and you know there's so much
to do with you know using and misusing
historical parallels but but you know
what what do you see
um of any resonance in in those two
episodes you know that's a great
question let me get to that in a moment
i'm sort of dying to tell more about the
rumsfeld story because
was
accomplished speech on the aircraft
carrier where he announces that combat
operations in iraq are over this was in
may 2003 and of course that was just the
start of the war in iraq it was this
massive public relations blunder that
really came back to haunt him but people
do forget on that same day russell went
to kabul where he announced the same
thing in afghanistan that combat
operations had ended
because clearly they were trying to make
give people this impression that these
two wars had been were over and we could
declare victory but the thing about
rumsfeld's speech in particular in kabul
was uh i obtained some documents against
some army oral history interviews with
army officers who were were at military
headquarters in kabul at that very time
and they were shocked that rumsfeld said
this they said what is what is he
talking about that combat operations are
over we never got any order or anything
on paper saying to stop fighting and
they rattled off all these uh named
combat operations like operation
mountain lion and operation this and
that that were still going on so russell
this again this isn't just spin this is
rumsfeld lying because he knew and and
the military knew that this just was not
true but you know those are two great
examples i think we kind of
uh sometimes we don't
we take people's word for it and it's
hard to disprove when they say something
that that seems off but i mean these are
just two
mammoth falsehoods uh in 2003 and 2014
that the war was over when it clearly
wasn't
um but getting back to vietnam sorry uh
this is this is another fascinating
comparison right you know there's sort
of this reluctance i think among us
government officials to ever compare
anything to vietnam because the
connotation is one of failure and of not
telling people the truth so nobody wants
to associate anything
with the outcome of the war in vietnam
but
the parallels have been there from the
beginning
in fact you know when back in the fall
of 2001 right after president bush
announced the start of uh military
operations in afghanistan he was asked
at a prime time news conference uh mr
president are you worried that we might
get sucked into a quagmire like vietnam
and bush was dismissive of this he was
very confident and said oh no we learned
our lessons from vietnam uh we're not
gonna get stuck we're not gonna get
bogged down in afghanistan like in
vietnam and rumsfeld
would say this too he would you know he
would mock reporters who asked him are
we going to get struck like vietnam and
anytime someone brought up the word
quagmire
he would really make fun of people and
put them down
but again the irony is that six months
into the war
rumsfeld writes one of these memos to
his generals uh saying uh i'm really
worried that we aren't gonna be able to
get our troops out of afghanistan unless
we come up with a plan to stabilize the
country and he ended the memo with one
word it said help with an exclamation
point so again here in public they're
dismissing any comparison to vietnam but
in private that's exactly what they're
worried about
and i think in some ways fast forward
almost 20 years that's what happened
with the biden administration uh joe
biden was asked i think it was just in
july
uh
when
u.s troops had all but withdrawn from
afghanistan he was asked you know could
there be a saigon moment in afghanistan
meaning you know where you'd have an
evacuation off the roof of the u.s
embassy and helicopters and biden was
very dismissive of this you know oh man
no way that could never happen that's
not going to happen that's not what's
going on
well of course you know a few weeks
later
uh things actually look worse than a
helicopter off the roof of the embassy
you had those images of the
uh us air force c-17
transport plane with these afghans
running down the runway trying to cling
to it
uh i mean it just the images were
terrible and we ended up evacuating
helping to evacuate more than a hundred
thousand people in just a few weeks so
you know i mean that yes there are
parallels to saigon and vietnam you know
certainly there are differences in in
in different aspects of it but the
overall perception and the way we had to
flee really while the enemy that meaning
the taliban is taking over
i mean those are strong parallels and
those are images that are hard to get
out of your head
i want to ask just a couple of more
questions before i i um
go to the to i'm looking at these very
good questions from
from the audience um you know and one is
you know how much this i hope this is
not too too parsing but how much
do you think that
u.s officials truly just flat out lied
to the public about the war
versus
you know the kind of
putting a good face on things sometimes
or even just the kind of self-delusion
that sometimes happens in
in wartime at the highest levels
well and that's another good question
when i say lie i don't i don't say that
lightly you know at the washington post
where if anything criticized for being
too hesitant
to use that word we give people the
benefit of the doubt that if we don't
know what's in their mind when they say
something we just point out that it's a
false statement or contradicted by
evidence and things like this but in in
researching this book again i've covered
the pentagon for many years i've been a
foreign correspondent before that so i'm
used to spin and people giving happy
talk uh and i get that i'm not saying
that that's a lie but there's certainly
a lot of that a lot of misleading
statements but when you look at the
actual documents
and
the correlation in time between what
somebody said in public and what they
clearly knew at the time was true or
false i mean you can't do anything but
conclude they were lying like with
rumsfeld saying
major combat operations are over in in
2003. i mean there's no doubt he knew
that wasn't true at the time and you
you've got contemporaneous evidence and
testimony by people who served under him
who said this just flat out wasn't true
and just like obama saying it was the
end of
the combat mission he knew that wasn't
true he was the commander-in-chief and
he had authorized these troops to keep
fighting in combat
so those are two big
big lies right there's no way around it
i mean how else can you describe it at
the same time you're right it wasn't
throughout the world there also was a
lot of
uh
you know inflation of expectations a lot
of uh people spinning things a lot of
rosy characterizations of what's going
on that you know doesn't quite cross the
line into lying but you know add it all
up and it's just it's not a good record
of anybody telling the truth as i
mentioned the one general who told the
truth got fired and i think the lesson
out from that was
you can't be honest with the american
people and
you know the old cliche is you know
truth is the first casualty of war so
there's a long history of this
but at the same time when is there a
more important moment for our us
government leaders to be honest with the
public when people's lives are on the
line and we're committing troops and a
lot of money
to a conflict halfway around the world i
mean they need to start being honest
about it
in his speech
this week president biden stated
categorically that the war in
afghanistan is over
um at the same time
he said we will maintain the fight
against terrorism in afghanistan um
and we just don't need to fight a ground
war to do it we can strike you know from
afar
um with american boots on the ground
very few if needed
right um
there seemed to be some wiggle room
there you know and
based on what you've
seen over the past two decades you know
what do you imagine future
us military action in afghanistan if any
could could look like
well that's you know another phrase that
people should watch out for is boots on
the ground that's something that obama
said a lot and people may forget this
but when he sent troops to back to iraq
and syria
at first he you know said particularly
in syria there will be no boots on the
ground we're not putting u.s troops on
the ground in syria and of course they
did right and reporters would say this
what do you mean no boots on the ground
there's we've got pictures of literally
of boots on the ground of americans and
they would use this to kind of again
give people this misleading image that
we don't have lots of troops there uh
you know i i do think biden
i take him at his word for the moment
that there is this complete troop
withdrawal from afghanistan and we're
not going to be you know there's no
afghan army or government to advise
anymore right so
that role's gone that's vanished there's
no purpose for having them there uh
we're not going to be working
hand-in-glove with the taliban that same
way but does that mean that the cia
won't send operatives in i i doubt i
think that you know the cia will try and
find some way to have a presence they'll
have proxy forces perhaps uh you know
the war is going to continue in a
different phase it's just not going to
be this overt
military conflict but you know it could
be more like um you know you think in
the afghan war when the soviets were in
there we were involved in that war even
though we didn't technically have boots
on the ground but we were a big player
in the war between the soviets and the
afghan resistance at that point i'm not
saying that's what's going to happen now
but i'm just saying you're right there's
a lot of wiggle room there for the u.s
to remain
involved in afghanistan for
counter-terrorism operations
yeah there were there were suitcases of
money on the ground um back in back in
the 80s um
so
a few questions um from
from the
the audience um
one um let's see
uh gabriel asks um you know craig thank
you for your reporting since the pull
out from afghanistan there's been some
conversation around how u.s military
contractors have benefited from the the
prolonged war
did you come across this topic in the
course of your reporting um if so what
what did it look like i mean the the
role of contractors in in war is also a
great way to kind of fudge boots on the
ground um so what what did you what did
you uh make of that in the course of
your reporting whether for this book or
just your your overall reporting on on
the you know the global war on terror
well exactly and that's a good way to
be skeptical of what's going on but
certainly uh military contractors uh you
know they earned a lot of money
throughout the war in fact
just about everybody did in afghanistan
who had any kind of presence there the
irony is we spent so much money on
defense contracts and supplying our
troops whether it was ammunition or
water or food or
you know we had to send this enormous
amount of supplies halfway around the
world to this landlocked country in
afghanistan i mean i think people
sometimes don't realize what a
logistical challenge and feat that was
but we also spent enormous amounts of
money doing it and people
whether they're u.s defense contractors
foreign defense contractors uh afghans
uh even the taliban they all benefited
from this i mean one thing we would see
in the interviews for the afghanistan
papers was just how much money was being
siphoned off
uh not just by
uh
you know crooks in afghanistan you know
corrupt contractors but the taliban the
contractors had to pay protection money
to the taliban to let their convoys go
through and during obama's term during
the surge the military essentially
conducted a sort of review of all the
defense contracts uh at that point there
were more than 10 billion dollars a year
being spent in afghanistan and they
concluded that as much as 40 of the
money was being siphoned off and it
either went to uh criminal networks or
the taliban or corrupt afghan officials
so
everybody was benefiting from this uh
you know the good guys and the bad guys
and you know that certainly reduces any
incentive uh to end the fighting no
question
uh that gets uh perfectly to a question
that shmuel asks would things have ended
differently had we eradicated corruption
in afghanistan i guess one way to think
about that had we not
aggravated it
as well
well i think that's maybe the better way
to look at it and it's
uh
one state department official barnett
rubin said in an interview a lessons
learned learned interview he said you
know there's one necessary ingredient
for corruption and that's money and we
were the ones with all the money right
and because we were flooding afghanistan
with more money than it could possibly
absorb whether it was defense contracts
or nation building programs or
humanitarian aid uh inevitably a lot of
this money ended up in people's pockets
who who shouldn't have gotten it so
on one hand the united states was
lecturing the afghan government you know
you need to stamp out corruption and we
would train judges and set up courts to
deal with this uh on the other hand uh
we're making it happen because we're
we're sending all this money over there
you know there's there's one
episode in particular i was struck by
there was a diplomatic cable around 2006
that was sent by the us ambassador in
afghanistan at the time his name was ron
newman and he talked about meeting with
karzai hamid karzai the afghan president
in which uh the ambassador was berating
karzai about all these corrupt officials
on his payroll
uh and the afghan government and he was
saying that
in particular he was singling out
karzai's half-brother
ahmed wali karzai who was kind of a
strong man in kandahar in southern
afghanistan saying you need to remove
him from power he's corrupt to the core
and karzai of course was furious about
this because in part this is his brother
but his comeback was
you're the guys who are giving him all
the money that he's on the cia's payroll
and your the defense department's giving
them all these contracts why are you why
are you blaming me you're the guys who
are you know he's your best friend down
there and of course what can you say to
that right on one hand we lecture the
afghans you need to clean things up
but we were responsible for a lot of
those problems now the question is if we
had eradicated corruption would have
things been successful i i think it was
it was too difficult to eradicate
corruption both because of our role in
it and because the afghans saw this as a
way they didn't know when the money was
going to go away and they're all trying
to get a piece of it because they don't
know how the war is going to turn out i
think it would have been very hard
um
but the most devastating part of the
corruption was that it really made the
afghan people lose faith in their own
government they saw their own leaders as
a bunch of thieves who were looking out
for their own interests and so in the
end particularly in the rural areas uh
afghans sided with the taliban over
their own government and you know there
was no way we were going to win the war
if that was going to happen
uh getting back to this notion of
progress that we've we've discussed a
little bit uh bonnie asks you know
people point to improved conditions for
women and girls in afghanistan
in as progress
um is that
valid
sure absolutely um you know the question
is what is that progress going to
be sustainable or not and right now
that's a very open question a real
concern
um and this was but this is a really
good question because this gets to the
point of what we're trying what were we
trying to accomplish in afghanistan when
we went to war in 2001 it was to go
after al qaeda it wasn't to
uh
improve the lot of women and girls in
afghanistan that's certainly a noble
goal no question but that isn't why we
went to war but that became part of the
mission creep as it were
the bush administration
rightfully so said we should stick up we
should try and improve human rights in
afghanistan while we're there but this
became mixed up with the original
purpose of the war and i think a lot of
times the americans
you know we tend to we tend to project
our own values on another country and to
what degree can you really do that and
hope it will take root i don't know
kabul is a very different place from the
rest of afghanistan and that in the
urban areas in afghanistan like kabul or
herat or mazarish reef uh you know there
is uh
the the
the lot of women and girls has come a
long way you know they they're able to
go to school they don't have they can
take jobs they have important positions
in the government and you know i don't
want to minimize that
uh but in rural areas uh i i think we
were overreaching a bit for imposing our
own values and what afghans were ready
for and that has to be something that
comes from them in part and so this was
something we we wrestled with but again
never really sorted out what were we
hoping to accomplish what was our
purpose for being there and while there
was progress made in many regards
the whole question is now that we lost
the war what's going to happen
speaking of what's going to happen
let's get a little bit into into what
has just happened
president biden has expressed in recent
days that
uh look it was impossible to kind of get
out without some degree of chaos this
was always going to be the case and
and karina asks if this is true was
there would there have been any better
way the vitamin creation could have
avoided this chaotic exit from
afghanistan
well i think they could have planned a
lot better no question uh you know just
they clearly were uh caught off guard by
the degree by how quickly the taliban
was able to
take over provincial capitals and really
just march right into kabul without any
resistance they clearly
were not ready for that i think
intelligence assessments show that the
binding administration thought
they had at least a few months if not
longer that the afghan government and
army could hold out so they weren't
prepared for this and they should have
uh
they should have been they should have
had contingencies in place that you know
the us military plans for everything you
know they're at the pentagon there's
plans on the shelf for invading canada
nobody ever expects to use them but
there's plans and i am surprised that we
didn't have better plans in place for a
sudden evacuation if we needed it and
particularly the
planning was uh
was deficient in trying to process
immigrant visas for afghans who would
help the united states as interpreters
or civil servants or other roles like
that
the us government knew this dating back
to the obama administration that there
was this huge backlog of visa
applications that hadn't been processed
and couldn't be done quickly i think the
binding administration had made some
improvements in that in the margin since
january but uh that was something that
we should have foreseen and should have
been better prepared for uh so in the
end we had to do this big evacuation but
uh you know we were just we there was no
way we could process all those
applications we were just pulling people
out willy-nilly and it was just very
very chaotic so
yes they could have done better at the
same time you know there's never any
easy way to end a war that you're losing
it's easy to start one but it's a lot
harder to end it
and you look at the last seven years
obama and trump and biden all tried to
end the war obama promised he would by
the end of his second term and the
reason he didn't is he was worried
there'd be a collapse of the afghan
government so we kept troops over there
same thing with trump he promised to end
the war but his generals advised him
said look if you pull out now the afghan
government could collapse uh so you need
to keep some troops here even though you
cut this deal with the taliban to
withdraw he kind of kicked it down the
road for biden to deal with so yeah
biden made the decision to finally end
the war and it probably was going to be
chaotic no matter what but it didn't
have to be that chaotic
uh
i have time for for a couple of more
questions um i'm gonna focus in on on
two that have to do uh with
with journalism um both you know in a
micro sense and in a macro sense i'll
i'll take the the micro sense first
linda asks
do you have researchers or other staff
that work with you or was this a solo
operation
did you work on other assignments over
the course of your work on the
afghanistan papers
uh no i didn't work on other assignments
this this was my full-time job when we
were publishing the series in the post
and then for
uh
you know in 2020 and so far in 2021 this
is all i did was work on the book and i
did my own research for it but i
certainly had an enormous amount of
assistance in the newsroom uh on the
original series in terms of uh
you know editors
fact checkers uh page designers we we
posted all these documents on the
internet and made them easy to search so
people could see them so
we had this huge effort on the staff
photographers videographers designers
so many people helped with this
i was the the sole reporter on it on the
book again i was the author but had
tremendous help in the newsroom in terms
of editing and presentation and uh i did
have a fact checker full-time who could
who worked on fact checking for the book
that isn't something we ordinarily
usually reporters responsible for his or
her own fact checking for news stories
uh so if this is a washington post post
book and it drawn the talents of people
across the newsroom no question
i should point out as a as a fellow post
staffer that on projects like like these
it's not uncommon to see
um you know multiple
reporters and multiple bylines um and
one of the things that was so amazing
when afghanistan papers first came out
as a post project is that it was like
by craig whitlock you know and
it was um it was it was uh an
arduous um
and and extraordinary uh work but as
you're right there's there's a big team
um the other question about journalism
that um
is is more of a more of a macro question
um
comes from here let me scroll down to it
um
is uh robert robert asks did the press
fail in its role
to inform the american public
about the failures you're reporting now
yeah so i think the press always can do
a better job uh that said i maybe i
don't want to appear defensive but i
think
many reporters did a very good job of
covering the war in afghanistan and many
of these issues were reported were made
public about uh corruption in
afghanistan about uh about the problems
in training the afghan army and police
force uh you know certainly lots of
stories questioning uh whether this
withdrawal was going to go well and
negotiations with the taliban and you
know there was a lot of questioning
skeptical coverage through the years
but maybe you know we didn't do enough
of it or maybe certain outlets didn't do
more of it there's no question in recent
years since 2014 when obama
you know announced an end to the combat
mission a lot of reporters left kabul uh
and the television networks in
particular haven't given as much
attention over there and
afghanistan kind of was became the
forgotten war for a while so did we need
to cover it more closely absolutely i
mean we look at what happened and
there's no question we could have done
more but i also don't want to minimize
the risks and sacrifices that many
journalists made in going to afghanistan
and staying there the washington post
has had a bureau ever in kabul ever
since 2001 uh so of other newspapers uh
the wire services like the associated
press and reuters have covered things
there diligently and a lot of people
have put themselves at real risk to do
so so i i don't want to minimize that
but could we have done a better job you
know sure absolutely
but i don't know that we failed
we have i'm going to sneak in one last
um question i i was struck from the very
beginning that
uh both your your reporting in the post
on the afghanistan papers and the book
um you know has its genesis in in this
lessons learned project and that that
impulse is wonderful right to that that
military officials um and diplomatic
officials would
would want to um
you know get that down to to sort of
like assess what what they have learned
um
what do you think we have learned what
are the lessons learned from
the afghan war
i don't know that we've learned them uh
i think maybe we've learned that we
don't want to you know get in over our
head and take on these
enormous ambitious
uh
security projects to remake countries
overseas
particularly countries we don't
understand very well i think maybe
there's some humility in order here
uh and i think certainly in public
opinion nobody's clamoring uh to go
invade another country and try and
transform the society so i i think
there's a recognition that we
overreached in afghanistan for a long
time
um
that said i mean you know vietnam
happened and we thought we maybe we
learned our lessons from there and we
didn't and someday there's going to be
another crisis somewhere in the world
and the united states uh tends to react
militarily if it's under threat and the
question is how are we going to to react
and how are we going to deal with a
situation that may come up that may be
similar but in some other country and
some other part of the world and
you know i'm i'm skeptical that we've
learned our lessons the lessons may be
there
to read and see and hear
but are they going to sink in i guess
that's the question and only time will
tell with that
well craig i can't imagine
a more timely moment for your work to
come out uh in in this book um and i
i hope that it'll help us
um
reflect and and and maybe even learn
some of those those lessons
well thank you carlos thank you for the
the great discussion i really want to
thank the striker center for hosting us
it was a real privilege and honor uh
these are terrific questions and
it is encouraging
uh the public response people do want to
know what went wrong in afghanistan and
they want to hear it straight and they
want an explanation of what happened
over the last 20 years how things could
go wrong seemingly so quickly and i i
hope the book has those answers and will
give people a much better feel
for for why things went wrong
on behalf of the stryker center craig
and carlos we want to thank you for
joining us this evening and thank you
all of you for tuning in
and uh please check our website for many
great fall programming and wishing
everyone celebrating a very happy rosh
hashanah thank you
and now on book tv we're live with
former vanderbilt university professor
and vice chair of